la ciudad de la samba está totalmente
parada el único almacén de producción
con actividad es el de la escuela de
samba unidos de viradouro pero son solo
obreros preparando los daños causados
por un incendio en abril pasado con la
pandemia
álex fat director de carnaval de la
agrupación campeona en 2020 no puede
organizar los eventos que permiten
recaudar fondos a lo largo del año
y que montamos todas las piezas de la
carroza están aquí preparadas para ser
llevadas a una escuela de samba de nova
friburgo es este tipo de
comercialización que hacemos lo que nos
ayuda para mantener nuestro carnaval en
este tiempo de dificultad
en la escuela y ha elegido la trama de
su próximo desfile un homenaje al
carnaval de 1919 es conocido como el
mayor del siglo por sus excesos
intensidad después de la pandemia de
gripe española pero con todo parado
hasta que se tome una decisión
definitiva muchos han perdido un empleo
seguro
de esa forma el taller así nos afecta
mucho estamos tristes no solo porque
estas personas no están aquí sino
también porque sabemos que ellas se
están pasando por momentos difíciles en
sus casas hasta para mantenerse
[Música]
sin poder ensayar juntos al aire libre a
causa de la cuarentena los miembros del
brujo de calle que es trabajadora
también se adaptan a lo largo del año
marcelo uno de los fundadores de la
banda creada en 2008 recibe un salario
gracias a las clases de percusión
desde el momento en que pudimos hacerlo
la única manera que encontramos para
mantener un mínimo para subsistir fue
poner las clases en formato online y sin
colocar los formato una e
algo con lo que la pandemia no acabará
en brasil es con la pasión de sus
músicos